do you bring the kids ever to a show so
they can see you on stage this is the
first they saw me last night and I think
it's the first time they've ever really
seen me is that a big decision remember
do they know their mom is Gwen
Stefani um they do the older one is real
clear on it years ago when I wasn't
doing anything and not having hits or
anything he was like Mom you need to
make a hit like you need to like do you
know like he was like really like that
about and then when it then when it was
happening I was like look I got this is
on the chart he he didn't really have
react the way I thought he
was you have an unusual parenting style
well what do they call it is there a
name for so attachment parenting is like
the umbrella term isn't it true the kids
sleep in your bed till all the every
night people do it a lot of different
ways the fact is in the early stages of
parenting and breastfeeding it is normal
for mammals to sleep near their babies
and most adults don't want to sleep
alone so so children also don't want to
sleep alone so there's there's a way
that there's a set of and also because
like this is my Neuroscience you know
perspective as well it's hormonally Ben
you know beneficial for Mammal babies to
sleep near their moms in particular
that's not bad my kids have never
negotiated with me bargained with me to
stay up one more glass of water they
don't fear sleep sleep is a safe place
they now sleep together they're five and
a half and E two little boys they they
don't fear sleep or nighttime and like
yeah as a kid like I hated nighttime I
would C I was up all night like that's
not good either and when I hear people
like oh I can't get my kid to stay in
bed maybe they just want to know that
you're around and be closer I don't know
figure it out breastfeeding till the kid
is four right that's you okay so that's
that's hold on in attachment paring yes
and the Ley League International and
organizations that support breastfeeding
I'm also a lactation educator counselor
so I come from also like a sort of
educated lactation perspective yes
breastfeeding is a normal natural thing
that primates do and they often will do
it longer than is socially acceptable to
Western culture I was not breastfeeding
my four-year-old on the subway when he
was two yes there was a trip from Coney
Island where no one would have had a
good Subway trip if I didn't breastfeed
that kid right that happened I kept him
quiet happy and like everything was fine
so you know part of your parenting the
kids do not wear diapers oh no so my
kids did not wear diapers that's called
elimination communication but it's
actually I know it's actually separate
from attachment parenting many people
some people who do attachment parenting
do this but yeah so you uh basically
babies are born giving signals when they
pee and poop I promise and if you learn
those signals and reinforce them they
will give them stronger and clearer and
I we taught our kids to sign this is the
Sign Language sign for potty by the time
they were 12 months old they were
signing for potty they couldn't walk
talk or eat solids they only breastfed
but they could sign for the potty before
they could even walk talk or the same
Theory with a dog like dogs will teach
you can teach them to go to the bathroom
outside right so you're more training
yourself to to learn the cues that the
baby will give and if you don't
reinforce them a baby will stop giving
those cues and it's not for everyone
believe me but yeah especially with boys
it's easy we just hold them up over a
tree and they would wear cloth diapers
but then they were in underwear by like
17 months there's no reward and
Punishment there's no gold star there's
no chocolate chips it's literally that
they have taught you what to look for
and it's an a fascinating method of
communicating with your child because
all they know is that you understand
them and are there to support them how
do you have a life of your own when
you're that I mean you devote every
second of your life to your kids um well
look in their first years ad it no no no
and in their first years it was very
intense it's very intense and the fact
is especially like in the industry and
the way I like why aren't you going for
martinis with your girlfriends why AR
you going away for weekends with us and
yeah it's hard but I think what's
amazing and what always existed in human
and and primate culture was a group of
women who supported each other in what
they were doing and took turns doing
things F we've lost that in our
communities but that's why people do
things like go to these Leche League
meetings and go to these like holistic
moms organization meetings because you
meet like-minded people who won't make
you feel crappy that you're not going
for
martinis you don't see this in any of
your kids though by the way you don't
see them with the genetics of where
they're starting to hurt themselves are
they my you know I have a 22-year-old
daughter and she was always much smarter
than me and my
friends and I have a six-year-old
daughter she's very intell my my son
eight-year-old is very bright but he is
wired like my father he's very excitable
so he doesn't know what I do I don't
show them he'd probably get into it
right oh do they go they don't see the
movies have they ever seen Jackass
movies the little ones no no way what
age do we think it's appropriate for
them to start seeing yeah when are you
going to tell them who you really are um
he told him he's a heart
surgeon they they came into my office
one day and there was a a picture of me
getting run over by a buffalo and I felt
so I was like oh no good I that's just
daddy having fun with his friends it's a
stunt yeah and so well with my daughter
she never saw anything on the shows that
was you know uh that I felt that was
inappropriate and finally when she was
14 she could see Jackass 3D but I made
her sit beside me and I had a list of
the whole movie and I said certain parts
you have to cover your eyes cover your
ears or cover both oh she did don't you
think now she's seen she must have seen
him without oh yeah well she's 22 now
but at 14 I felt for my children I'm not
saying for everyone's children they but
for mine I felt it was I felt it was and
and I'm kind of a helicopter parent with
right my kids I don't if they're
climbing on something I'm standing right
under them cuz I don't want them to get
hurt that's amazing that's why I don't
want my son's knowing too much of what I
do because he has a funny look in his
eye he's got that look does Uncle steo
ever come over and staple his nuts let's
say just for the they don't do it they
they've come over but they don't do that
in front of the kids so what do your so
what do your little ones think you're up
to I mean you they they're like hey
Dad's a movie star uh they just think
you're in the movies right they know
that I make movies and why can't they
see them and that's what my daughter
asked when when are you going to make a
movie I can we can see yeah how old are
you my oldest is 19 oh and then I got my
middle daughter Zoe is going to be 16 in
September right and then mcnie the
little rascal is uh six are you a cool
dad well what do you do when the kids
say to you hey Dad we're going to smoke
weed like do you go oh that's horrible I
can't do it with you no you know it's
one of those uh strange conversations
owing to the fact that you know any
conversation where I'm trying to caution
them or discipline them is odd because
I've had a life of excess so it's very
difficult to
preach that's what I'm saying so how did
you handle that what did you say well I
I do always encourage them you know if
you're going to smoke it then come to me
you know let me know yeah sure you know
what I mean when you preach to them no
not that I it just that I'd rather it be
done in a way like to me the biggest
problem with it there's no problem with
herb the problem with herb is the abuse
of it right and so you know but if you
treat it in a sacred manner not to say I
always
had is it um a weird decision to uh
whether or not your kids can see you on
stage in other words that's a very
different you um true you know and it's
it's a very freaky thing for kids to see
that and it's almost like you want to
keep them away from that right yeah
they've been so exposed to so much
though like that little the first one
from the moment he came out or no even
when he was in the belly he had been
photographed every single day of his
life I cannot you know he used to get so
upset like Paparazzi and he wouldn't get
out of the car he would cry and he was
just hounded you didn't ask for any of
that no and so he's sort of used to that
part of it and then I don't know I think
that um like I had a meet and greet
yesterday and he wanted to go with me to
that and that was like I don't know if
you need to go to that but he did
because it's seeing mom being worshiped
in a way that probably is healthy I
never really understood all those well
it was pretty cool though how it worked
out is there was a girl a woman that
came that had multiple sclerosis and she
was explain her mom brought her in the
wheelchair and her sister she was
explaining it to me and so it was really
an amazing way to show him how if you
just you know how if you use your talent
and your gift that God gave you like you
can actually help other people it was
really crazy cuz um recently not that
recently like a few years ago I sat down
with s McCartney and I got to talk to
her about what it was like for her can
you imagine being Paul McCartney's
daughter and then I just saw um Georgia
Jagger and got to talk to her about her
like her being a child of and it was so
helpful for me to get their perspective
and they say because I would think
having a parent that is that famous like
you I would somehow think it would be
like oh how could I ever be anything in
living in my mother and father Shadow
you know what I mean but look at them
both of those girls have have their own
lives their own careers they're such
they're so cool so what was the secret
what did they say how did they negotiate
all that I think they just had really
good parents you know and like I think
that it just helped me I think
everything works out as long as there's
love and you know what I'm saying and
that's what I'm learning so much is that
because I had such an idealistic
childhood it's really hard for me to
understand that that there's different
kinds of families and different kinds of
like experiences you can have and it
doesn't it doesn't mean it's not going
to be awesome for them do you know what
I'm saying saying so that's one thing
I've had to learn and it's taken me a
long time to get to like open to that
Bron you know it's a pretty remarkable
career I guess if somebody said to you a
young guy said to you hey I'm thinking
of going into acting you would probably
tell him yeah it's a great life it's a
great career but I get asked this
question a lot I do a lot of fan
conventions I have done in recent years
and I've loved it when you you like that
kind of thing you like going into a yeah
there's just people who are
really uh for whatever their personal
reasons are they're really
fulfilled or happy just to make your
acquaintance if only for a few moments
and I find that really gratifying and
affirming and sometimes there are uh
those also who I can clock from across a
convention um room Hall who I can tell
right away on that that he's on the
Spectrum you know I can you know that
there's somebody who needs a little more
love a little more time because they're
Autistic or they have Aspergers and this
is their world this is where they belong
and um no matter all of the noise
surrounding the hysteria that goes into
the whole um celebrity [__] I always
always um stop a train to have a moment
with them because my oldest son is
autistic right and I know I know how
meaningful it is to their families and
to them and um
it's I'm
sorry it means a lot to to feel like you
can gratify someone just just simply by
showing
up it means a lot it seems like there is
so many people who have autistic uh
children I I mean I speak to a lot of
people about this and it is probably one
of life's most difficult things as a
parent because you worry your whole life
will my kid be able to be independent
what happens after I die will my kid be
okay like what's the plan here can I
make good with this what will the Legacy
be um I I I know of course what what can
we do other than give ourselves a break
and muddle our way through it together
and do what works and do what works
until it doesn't work anymore and then
find something new and yes you will have
to fight with school boards and yes
there will be weird people that you meet
along the way who have a completely
different agenda compared to what the
purpose of sending a kid to a special
needs school is I
you're going to encounter a lot of
really colorful people and how you
navigate that all comes down to how much
you know that everything's going to be
okay I can't imagine your life with two
kids I get a little sense of it from the
book for sure yeah but I still I still
picture Andy con as a guy who is
frustrated that he can't have that wild
life anymore that you're really a torn
individual I'm pretty good with it there
are occasion last weekend I was in the
city with my kids I had jury duty late
last week and it was on Friday and I was
like ah going with the kids out east for
24 hours is this going to be worth it
and the car ride and whatever so we
stayed in the city and I had friends my
ex was on Fire Island posting up a storm
and I was
like as my four-year-old was taking me
for a ride and telling me mean and
yelling at me and this and that I was
like what am I doing right now but it's
hard right hard give up it's hard to
give up the the fun life that you had
previously but it was it was I did the
right thing at the right time and I'm so
glad I did it there's a couple of things
in your book I do not believe I do not
believe that you do not have help at
night to uh I don't but I mean it would
be perfectly reasonable if you I don't
have a Liv I don't want any one living
in and I last night Ben got me up twice
my daughter got me up once and that is
the that is he got me up at 1 wanting to
come in my room I said no and then I
folded at 4: and he came in my bed and I
and you're not neurotic you don't go oh
[__] I got to do a a what What Happens
Live I got to do a radio show doing an
intervie at around 4:15 after he fell
asleep in my bed and then Lucy started
crying I was laying there and I was like
can a man be fresh for the Stern Show
for one you know in my mind I was I was
like you're I'm doing the Stern Show I
went to bed last night at 10:30 hoping
that I could really come in here you
know just
fresh are you thinking about doing
something on TV um I had an opportunity
recently and I'm I I just it was it's so
hard I'm really um by no means stopping
my job at all um but I just I've had a
really hard time personally figuring out
how to I can't miss out on my kids right
now you don't want to go away from home
for a long time and I don't want to be
at if you do a series you're going to be
there all the time I I wonder cuz I
don't know the hours of a series CU I've
never done it so maybe there's something
to learn there and maybe that's the
balance but I know on a film you wake up
before they are up and you come home
after they're asleep and I'm not willing
to miss out on this I've done this for
40 years it's so easy to put a side for
a minute yes and just be like I need to
be a mother to these children yeah now I
know a lot of people in Hollywood that
really aren't mothering their children
because their careers do come first and
there's that rub I mean and and I
understand why to keep a career going
you you know you only have so many years
you got to pick the right project you
got to be so ensconced in that world and
it's really a drag especially for women
right you got I think it takes a lot of
focus and then it really monopolizes
your time and it's you know I I can't
figure it out if I'm a failure for not
knowing how to balance it then I'm a
failure but I'm going to fail on the
side of you know but I still work I have
a beauty company I wrote a book I'm
finding you know when one door shuts
another one opens I found time to write
a book cuz I wasn't on a movie you do
you ever sit there and go like you're
watching Claire Dan's in Homeland and
you go [__] I would love to love
Homeland yeah isn't that great I love
when she goes shy I'm like bring it baby
to get off those meds and let me see you
fly and nobody goes shy as you say
better than Claire D am I correct she
really does she goes Mushi she so I love
it yeah and when you're an actress and
you're sitting there watching Homeland
don't you ever say [__] I mean I love my
kids I want to be with them but Jesus
Christ be that that I the first thing I
do is go God bless her in this part she
should win every award for it I'm voting
for her then I think oh my God where are
they shooting that what country are they
in and then I think okay you know she's
a mom I should ask her how she's
balancing she told us she was in Germany
for 10 months doing that with her you
but she brought the kids with her yeah
of course you mentioned you love playing
with your son but immediately what I'm
thinking about here your name is
Tarantino and yet you never knew your
father yeah you met him once when he
when you were already a success and he
walked into I remember you told me you
walked into cfee me at a coffee shop
yeah right and you said [__] you I mean
I'm not talking to you you you were
never in my life yeah when you have a
father who abandons you uh it's heavy
duty I don't I don't make lie to that
yeah it does leave you hungry for a
father a male figure yeah sure and in
many ways Your Mother wasn't that
supportive of your career as we as we
mentioned earlier how did you figure out
how to have the capacity to love your
son and play with him when no one played
with you did you go to some kind of
special therapy CU I think this is
really important especially for people
who havea traumatized childhoods which
you had well you know look I'm I'm
definitely a lot older now so if I
hadn't gotten over some of that stuff
you know by by this point in time uh I
probably don't deserve to have kids but
it was one of those things where I've
always really really like kids and it's
one of those things where it's like uh
when I hang around uh if you hang around
like a couple that have kids and say
like you're really they're a couple of
your best friends then you're going to
meet a whole other lot of other couples
that have kids and they're going to come
over and I was always really good at at
at uh uh playing around with their kids
and and uh or even these groups of kids
that would come over and it' be
literally one of those things where all
the mothers would get these crushes on
me because mothers get crushes on on
adult men that are good with kids right
and they play I mean all the mothers had
crushes on me like my goodness Quinton
is so good with Raymond I can't believe
it Raymond doesn't really like anybody
but he'll sit down and know play with
Raymond and it's fantastic
and you hear how Quinton doesn't talk
down to Raymond he talks you he talks
slightly over his head but Raymond likes
that yeah no it's it's a it's a great
way to to meet women I mean it really
truly is but absolutely positively my
wife would not have married me if she
didn't think I was like good father
material